is Renfield going to get your blood
pounding when it drops in theaters on
April 14th or does it just suck here's
what the critics think about the
upcoming horror comedy Nicholas Cage is
returning to the big screen this month
as one of the most iconic fictional
characters of all time Dracula the Oscar
winner Stars alongside Nicholas Holt in
Renfield the new film from the Tamara
War director Chris McKay based on an
original idea by Walking Dead Creator
Robert Kirkman the film follows Holtz
Renfield the longtime henchman of Cage's
Dracula as he tries to start a new life
for himself away from his bloodthirsty
boss as its tongue-in-cheek premise
suggests the first Renfield trailers
have sold the film as a bloody but
light-hearted horror comedy that perhaps
more than anything else will give cage
the chance to chew up the scenery once
again now ahead of the film's
forthcoming April 14th release the first
reviews for Renfield are starting to
roll Lynn while an overall critical
consensus has yet to be cemented the
early Buzz for Renfield seems to be
mostly positive right now that isn't to
say that the early reviews for the film
have been overwhelmingly glowing as is
usually the case some critics have taken
to rinfield far more easily than others
consequence critic Liz Shannon Miller
for instance gave the film a b-plus
score in their review writing rinfield
knows exactly what it wants to achieve
and does so effectively Miller isn't the
only critic that enjoyed Renfield in
fact of the film's first 25 Rotten
Tomatoes reviews as of the making of
this video only five were negative while
each critic has offered their own
takeaways from the new horror comedy
those who enjoyed Renfield have
repeatedly emphasized the film's
combination of gory violence and chaotic
sense of humor Maggie bocella praised
the film's horror comedy tone in their
review for collider noting that it has
more in common with genre Classics like
1981's and American and Werewolf in
London than it does any of its scarier
vampire movie predecessors Coachella
went on to write ultimately Renfield is
fun primarily because it doesn't commit
too hard to any one thing moviegoers
will likely be delighted to hear that in
addition to the film's comic horror
Spirit Nicholas Cage's performance as
Dracula has been heavily praised indeed
the trailers that have been released for
Renfield have all suggested that Cage's
performance in it will be one of his
most unabashedly over the top in years
and it sounds like the actor has more
than delivered on that front
I am
in their review of the film for the
playlist Matthew monical specifically
praised the actor's turn as Fiction's
most iconic vampire writing in Nicholas
Cage's hands Dracula is the perfect
marriage between the rock star and the
jilted lover
exactly he won't grow to full power what
that's so weird why would you phrase it
like that as noted previously the early
reviews for Renfield haven't been
totally positive a handful of critics
have in particular criticized the film
for apparently failing to explore its
story as much as it potentially could
have the Seattle Times Moira McDonald
said as much in their negative review of
Renfield noting even with its brief
running time the movie runs out of steam
too quickly elsewhere variety critic
Owen gleiberman took issue with the
thinness of the film's script writing
it's a scatter shot Lark jam-packed with
ideas none of which really take hold
even some of the positive reviews for
Renfield have lamented the lightweight
nature of the film in their Scully
Vision review Dan Scully gave the horror
comedy a fresh rating on Rotten Tomatoes
but was also quick to note that it
doesn't quite live up to its own promise
rinfield proves to be a broadly pleasing
remarkably safe Studio comedy this isn't
necessarily A Bad Thing so much as it's
a case of squander potential with all
this in mind it seems safe to say that
Renfield delivers an enjoyable if not
necessarily outstanding experience at
the movie theater
focus on your needs
thanks to its mid-april release date the
film should in other words offer
interested viewers a refreshingly
R-rated blood-soaked counter to the
Super Mario Brothers which has taken the
movie going World by storm this month
foreign
[Music]